et notre invité politique ce matin c'est
stéphane troussel bonjour je rentre au
sel merci beaucoup d'être avec nous
président du conseil départemental de la
seine saint denis en détention pendant
20 minutes pour des interviews en
partenariat avec la presse quotidienne
régionale représenté par fabrice
veysseyre redon bojan fabrice bonjour
fabrique des journaux du groupe ebra
les journaux régionaux de l'est de la
france on commence par cette conférence
de presse hier conférence de presse
commune entre olivier ferrand et bruno
le maire bruno le maire qui a du coup
quelque peu éclipsé le point presse
d'olivier ferrand et ses annonces sur la
crise sanitaire
est ce que ça donne l'impression que
l'économie prend le pas sur le sanitaire
en tout cas il bien évidemment que comme
chacun d'entre nous moi je suis soucieux
des conséquences économiques et sociales
de cette crise sanitaire qui perdure et
qui a nouveaux entrants dans une étape
nouvelle et difficile et donc tout doit
être fait pour à la fois éviter un
recond finement généralisée parce qu'on
mesure et nous sommes en train de les
mesurer
en ce moment de manière particulièrement
forte les conséquences économiques
sociales dramatiques pour un certain
nombre de nos territoires et nos
habitants avec l'augmentation du chômage
des vagues de licenciements
l'augmentation du nombre des
allocataires du rsa et donc c'est des
souffrances terribles pour les plus
modestes de nos concitoyens
on va revenir sur ces sujets mais sur
les annonces de bruno le maire pierre
favresse alors sur les annonces de bruno
le maire mais j'ai une question vous
posez vous qui le rsa l'instant on va il
ya on va en parler également mais vous
êtes un département est particulièrement
concerné vous pensez que cette prise
économiquement et bien gérée par le
gouvernement
écoutez je pense en tout cas que du
point de vue du soutien aux entreprises
et des mesures d'urgence qui était
nécessaire
le gouvernement a fait ce qu'il fallait
j'attends de lui dans les prochains
jours et il y a urgence maintenant à ce
qu'il vienne en aide à nos concitoyens
les plus fragilisés par cette crise et
donc on parlera peut-être de la
situation des allocataires du rsa des
jeunes notamment qui
tout perdu en termes d'activité de cdd
ou d'intérim et des collectivités
locales et notamment les départements
qui vont faire face à une situation
financière particulièrement difficile
mais quand il quand il élargit quand il
renforce le fonds de solidarité quand il
prolonge le chômage partiel est ce que
ça répond pas justement à éviter un
chômage de masse et à éviter à ce que
des salariés se retrouvent dans des
situations précaires
oui bien sûr mais sauf que depuis un
certain nombre d'années malheureusement
le marché du travail a été
particulièrement flexibiliser des
situations de salariés de plus en plus
précarisés et ces mesures là elle touche
un certain nombre d'entre eux qui ont
des droits qui ont des possibilités
d'être indemnisés au chômage mais il ya
tous les autres tous ceux qui ont des
durées du travail trop faible tous ceux
qui comme les jeunes n'ont pas dehors
des heures de travail en nombre
suffisant pour avoir un certain nombre
de droits et donc la question et du des
allocataires du rsa et des jeunes de
moins 25 ans est posée quand vous
entendez bruno le maire et airs d'hier
la mesure de chômage partiel c'est
conforme à l'idée que nous nous faisons
de notre modèle social est ce que vous
approuvez cette phrase il faut déployer
actuellement toutes les mesures liées au
chômage partiel bien évidemment à la
fois pour maintenir des salariés en
situation de lien avec leur entreprise
et donc qu'il soit protégé pendant cette
période
mais il ya tous les autres tous les
autres et tous les autres c'est ce qui
encore une fois non pas le droit aux
indemnisation du chômage nous pas accès
au chômage partiel et je pense en
particulier aux jeunes de moins de 25
ans on va parler de la situation
sanitaire d'abord on va revenir bien sûr
sur ces questions du rsa et les
questions qui concernent spécifiquement
votre département mais la situation
sanitaire pas de nouvelles mesures en
ile-de-france annoncé hier le plan blanc
qui a été déclenchée par les hôpitaux
mais olivier ferrand n'a pas annoncé de
mesures de restriction est ce que vous
dites il va falloir sévir à un moment
qui ne les bonnes les mesures jusqu'à
maintenant sont les bonnes écoutez ce
qui est sûr c'est que le gouvernement
semble apprendre de ses erreurs et
notamment il semble avoir appris de la
situation marseillaise et d'être avec
les élus locaux les collectivités
locales comme les corps intermédiaires
dans un dialogue plus plus poussée plus
étroit et donc tant mieux et on voit que
quand les mesures sont préparés quand
elles sont concertés quand elles font
l'objet d'un travail je pense à la
situation des restaurateurs et bien
elles sont à la fois mieux appliquer
mieux acceptées par nos concitoyens
donc je pense que ça c'est la bonne
méthode moi je considère que la
situation est suffisamment difficile
pour que nous n'en rajoutons pas dans la
polémique sur sur ce sujet mais ce qui
est sûr c'est qu'il faut encore une fois
tout faire pour éviter leur confinement
généralisée et donc on voit bien
l'attention sur la question sur le sur
l'hôpital
actuellement on en est à 40 % des
livrets animations qui sont occupés par
des patients qu'au guide la rs10 qu'on
atteindra les 50 % et potentiellement
les 100% dès le début du mois de
novembre on est déjà à 60% dans un
département comme le mien on est à ce
moment que la situation sanitaire en
scène et bien 60 % des lits de
réanimation qui sont occupés par des
patients qu'aux vide
ce chiffre il est révélateur de quoi il
est surtout révélateur du fait que
l'offre de soins dans un département
comme le mien elle nouvelle ne
correspond pas aux besoins du territoire
trois fois moins de lits de réanimation
en seine-saint-denis et à paris et dans
les hauts-de-seine choses ont évolué
dans votre département en particulier
depuis le début de l'épidémie
non elles n'ont pas évolué elles n'ont
pas évolué suffisamment et d'ailleurs
mais pas suffisamment depuis un an je
rappelle que le premier ministre edouard
philippe est venu en seine saint denis
il y a un an
faire des annonces sur un état plus fort
en seine-saint-denis avec des mesures
attendues sur la police ou la justice
l'éducation et sur la santé
cette crise sanitaire qu'est ce qu'elle
a révélé elle a révélé elle a aggravé
les inégalités territoriales et sociales
en particulier en matière de soins il ya
un certain nombre d'engagements qui ont
été pris et annoncé notamment sur la
des investissements massifs dans un
certain nombre d'hôpitaux de
seine-saint-denis je constate sur des
investissements matériels ou immatériels
et il faudrait bien plus en matière
humaine est également et dorion il
attend pour pour facilement les éléments
vous n'en avez pas vu la couleur en fait
c'est vraiment bien évidemment j'en ai
pas vu la couleur ou trop peu et donc il
est temps d'accélérer aujourd'hui sur
ces questions là c'est à la fois
indispensable par rapport à nos
concitoyens par rapport aux questions
sanitaires c'est aussi indispensable
d'accélérer les investissements en
général pour relancer l'investissement
aujourd'hui n'y a pas plus de lits en
seine saint denis qu'il n'y en avait au
mois de mars
bien évidemment connu est ce qu'on vient
examen est ce que l'on peut dire
stéphane troussel que dans l'hypothèse
où l'épidémie reviendrait à son niveau
initial celui qu'on a connu au printemps
votre département des toujours pas prêt
je constate simplement oh regardez
aujourd'hui les chiffres 60 % des livres
et animations en seine saint denis sont
déjà occupés par des patients qu'aux
vide mais c'est le résultat du fait que
nous avons trois fois moins de lits de
réanimation en seine-saint-denis pour un
département qui est le deuxième
département plus le plus peuplé d'île de
france après paris
nous sommes désormais en nombre
d'habitants devant les hauts de seine
il y a trois fois moins de lits de
réanimation syndic dans les
hauts-de-seine et et la réalité c'est
que eh bien pour faire face à cette
situation il faut des efforts dans la
durée massif
j'ai signé avec plus d'une vingtaine
d'élus de seine-saint-denis il ya
quelques jours un appel pour dire à quel
point il fallait accélérer les
investissements en matière de santé dans
notre département parce que sinon la
situation elle sera malheureusement tout
aussi difficile que celle que nous avons
vécue au mois d'avril au mois d'avril on
parlait beaucoup de ce manque de masques
pour pour la population et dans les
hôpitaux aujourd'hui il semble qu'ils
aient un autre problème c'est un manque
de gand est ce que vous vous avez été
alerté sur cette pénurie dans vos
hôpitaux
à ce stade non ce que je crois par
contre c'est qu'il faut là encore en
matière par contre de dépistage il faut
aller beaucoup plus loin que ce qui a
été fait c'est obsolète
c'est pas la bonne politique de salut
c'est la bonne politique c'est à dire
que à la fois les 20 centres en ile de
france
mais vous voyez bien que lé encore dans
le département qui ne peuplées comme la
seine saint denis 1
millions six cent mille habitants le
deuxième après paris il y a deux centres
de test l'un a bondi l'un à saint denis
donc il faut aller une fois les plus
loin il faut aller plus loin sur le sur
ses centres de dépistage par ailleurs il
faut aussi continuer ses actions qui
consistent à aller vers les populations
parce qu'on sait très bien que nous
avons besoin de ce lien d'extrême
proximité d'aller vers les publics pour
continuer de tester et d'isoler et de ce
point de vue là encore nous avons besoin
de raccourcir les délais de qui
permettent d'isoler quand il y a des cas
positifs et les cas contacts aujourd'hui
c'est d'aider que ce soit dans le délai
de prescription du test enfin en tout
cas de réalisation du test et la
production du résultat est-ce que vous
avez noté une réduction concrète de ces
j'ai l'impression que ça s'améliore mais
à l inverse je pense qu'il faut aller
beaucoup plus vite beaucoup plus loin
quand il s'agit d'identifier et d'isoler
les cas positifs et les cas contacts il
faut que la machine administrative
accélère encore sur la nécessité de
repérer quand il ya un conte un cas
positif tous les cas contacts autour et
les mesures à prendre pour justement
éviter les chaînes de contamination pour
aller justement continuer à parler de
cette crise n est taré et de la pauvreté
du coup qu'elle engendre on va parler
notamment du rsa fabrice oui vous
d'évoquer tout à l'heure stéphane
troussel le rsa le rsa qui a un rôle
majeur dans une période comme celle là
certains me demandent une augmentation
du rsa vous faites partie de ces élus
bien évidemment que le niveau du rsa et
bien et bien trop faible mais donc ça
c'est la première chose mais la seconde
c'est qu'effectivement nous sommes nous
allons être confrontés les chiffres le
montrent dans mon département d'ici la
fin de l'année je pense qu'on sera entre
6 7 8 % d'augmentation par rapport à
l'année précédente que les départements
qui assume de plus en plus à la place de
l'état cette dépense
il faut savoir quand même que la dépense
de rsa n'est compensée par l'état vers
les départements qu'à hauteur de 55 60 %
aujourd'hui dans le budget du
département de la seine saint denis par
exemple c'est plus de 200 millions que
le département doit seul consacré à
cette allocation de solidarité nationale
et nous nous n'allons pas pouvoir faire
face c'est que vous aviez alertés sur le
fait que ça m'était votre budget votre
situation financière en péril c'est
encore le cas aujourd'hui bien
évidemment et ça le sera encore plus
d'ici la fin de l'année
c'est nous allons être confrontés à une
augmentation en seine-saint-denis de
vraisemblablement de 35 millions de
hausse de la dépense du rsa avec
parallèlement une baisse de nos recettes
d'à peu près de même niveau
et donc c'est une impasse budgétaire de
70 millions d'euros
c'est autant de moyens financiers que
nous ne pourrons pas consacré par
exemple aux investissements alors que
les collectivités locales les
départements en particulier réalise 70%
de l'investissement public et qu' il
nous faut accélérer dans cette période
pour relancer l'activité économique
le soutien aux entreprises et donc à
l'emploi et aux salariés donc vous dites
concrètement il faut augmenter le rsa
parce que les personnes qui le touche en
ont besoin mais c'est à l'état de
prendre en charge cette augmentation
mais il faut absolument surtout non
seulement effectivement de soutenir le
rsa je pense les le niveau du rsa il
faut également faire en sorte que les
jeunes de moins de 25 ans puisse être
soutenue pendant cette période je
rappelle quand même que la france est un
des pays aujourd'hui qui n'a toujours
pas élargi ses minima sociaux aux moins
de 25 ans et l'état est venu en aide aux
entreprises pour les soutenir
aux salariés qui peuvent avoir accès au
chômage partiel l'état doit maintenant
venir en aide
aux plus fragiles aux allocataires du
rsa et à la collectivité départementale
qui verse le rsa dans des discussions
actuellement entre les départements et
le gouvernement sur la gestion de ce
reste à charge du rsa
en tout cas moi je plaide à nouveau
encore plus dans cette période avec
notamment les départements de gauche
pour qu' il y ait un refinancement
national de la location du rsa parce que
les démentis de l'internationaliser pour
vouloir les départements ne pourront pas
faire face dans cette période de crise
majeure
autre sujet que les départements à gérer
c'est la question des mineurs isolés
fares
oui une question qui a fait qu a fait
polémique vous faites partie des
présidentes de département qui dépose
plainte contre polémiste eric zemmour
qui a considéré les mineurs isolés comme
des truands pour faire un résumé vous
cette plainte vous pensez que le
président de l'association des
départements de france doit également la
dépose et vous accompagner dans cette
démarche
oui bien sûr d'abord parce que eric
zemmour a été déjà condamné pour
incitation à la haine raciale et donc
ses propos sont insupportables la
généralisation à partir d'un acte odieux
d'un individu isolé isolé et de 2,2 de
généraliser à l'ensemble de ces enfants
et ces jeunes est quelque chose
d'insupportable donc parce que les
actifs
il ya quand même un problème derrière se
dirait cette polémique qui ne confondons
pas tout dans vous êtes dignement qu'il
y ait des qu'il y ait des situations et
le le fait qu'ils étaient évoquées est
gravissime et donc cet individu doit
bien évidemment être lourdement condamné
mais ça n'autorise pas eric zemmour a
basculé dans la la généralisation et
encore une fois l'incitation à la haine
raciale donc mais cette démarche donc je
refuse d'entrer dans avec le petit doigt
sur
l'assimilation que faire eczéma ou
rentrer des délinquants et la situation
de ces jeunes mineurs isolés étrangers
et juste sur la plainte parce que vous
n'avez pas été clair plusieurs
départements ont porté plainte est ce
que vous dites là dominique bussereau
qu'il faut qu'il porte plainte au nom de
l'adf ou pas oui bien évidemment ce
serait ce serait totalement légitime que
l'adf parce qu'elle a la responsabilité
de la protection de ces enfants et ces
jeunes s'associe au nom de l'ensemble
des départements de france à 7 à cette
plainte pour faire condamner une
nouvelle fois eric zemmour dans son
n'avait pas encore personnellement mais
je savais ça ils envisagent de le faire
pas encore non alors il a dit dans nos
journaux que il envisager de vous
accompagner
il semblerait qu'il n'ait pas déposé
cette plainte c'est assez nouveau
finalement que des élus comme ça en
nombre dépose plainte contre un
personnage public
vous l'aviez déjà fait vous parle pas
c'est moi il m'est arrivé de déposer
plainte à plusieurs reprises vous avez
pour des propos pour une polémique bin
oui je crois je crois que oui mais en
tout cas là les avec avec cet individu
les bornes sont franchies
systématiquement et donc il est temps
d'une part qu' il soit une nouvelle fois
condamné mais peut-être aussi qu'il
n'est pas micros et caméras interdit
d'antenne en permanence écoutez c'est
insupportable à la publicité qui est
fait c'est à cet individu notre société
n'a pas besoin de ces polémiques raciste
en permanence elle est suffisamment
fragilisé pour que des individus comme
celui là ne continue pas à inciter à la
haine en permanence juste un mot parce
que quand même là la question des
mineurs isolés avec se pose pour les
départements il ya 2 milliards de restes
à charge là aussi c'est un coût pour les
départements vous appeler l'état à
mettre plus à la poche vous combien ça
coûte au département de la
seine-saint-denis combine le désole le
nombre comme dans la plupart des
départements de l'île de france 2 m et
n'a accueilli est prise en charge par la
seine-saint-denis a été multiplié par
trois en quelques années nous sommes
passés de 2 d'un peu plus de 500 à près
de 1700 aujourd'hui donc bien évidemment
que cette question allait majeur pour
les départements moi je dis que l'état
aurait tort de finalement et nous avons
également attaqué le fichier qui veut la
constitution du fichier auprès des
préfectures de ces mineurs parce que
j'ai toujours considéré nous le faisons
donc dans une démarche commune avec nos
amis du val de marne
nous avons toujours considéré que ce ne
sont ce n'est pas au département de
jouer le rôle de supplétif du ministère
de l'intérieur les départements ils ont
une mission de protection de l'enfance
et donc le l'état aurait tort de
considérer que ces jeunes doivent fait
systématiquement suspecté par ailleurs
je considère depuis toujours que si
l'état considère que les départements ne
jouent pas leur rôle ou que cette
question est d'abord une question
migratoire est bien qu'il assume sa
responsabilité d'évaluation et demi à
l'abri mais à partir du moment où ces
jeunes sont reconnus mineurs oui ils
doivent être protégés au titre des
engagements de la internationaux de la
france au titre de la protection de
l'enfance et les départements une
compétence par ailleurs quand on
investit pour l'insertion pour la
formation pour l'accompagnement pour la
protection et bien on obtient des
résultats mais encore faudrait-il que là
encore l'état ne laisse pas les
départements seuls sur cette question
les dépenses au titre des mineurs non
accompagnés et bien pour le département
de la seine saint denis c'est compensé à
hauteur de
8 % 8% et je me souviens que quand
président de la république a été élu en
2017 il a reçu une délégation des
départements de france à l'elysée pour
nous expliquer que cette question
effectivement et est insupportable du
point de vue financier pour les
départements et qu'il était temps que
l'état assume sa responsabilité
trois ans plus tard où en sommes-nous
sinon que la situation s'est une fois
encore dégradée pour les départements
allez on continue à parler de
l'actualité de votre département il ce
conseil municipal compliqué hein hier
soir à saint denis pour le nouveau maire
socialiste mathieu hanotin des agents
territoriaux et anciens élus ont envahi
la salle s'en prenant aux élus actuels
protestant contre la possible
augmentation de leur temps de travail on
le voit sur ces images qu'en pensez vous
rien n'autorise ces faits de violence
dans dans le tous ceux qui pratiquent
ces faits qui se sont comportés de cette
manière et bien se disqualifie du point
de vue du débat démocratique c'est
insupportable et malgré deux teintes
doit porter plainte bien évidemment il a
annoncé sa volonté de porter plainte au
nom de la ville de saint denis il
encourage chacun des élus qui ont été
violentés à le faire également
parce qu'encore une fois dans nos dans
une société démocratique
ces faits sont sont intolérables et
quand en plus ils sont encouragés mener
même par un certain nombre d'anciens
élus il ya quelque chose là qui du point
de vue du débat mme une démocratique ne
peut pas être accepté ça doit être
lourdement condamné autre question qui
concerne votre département elle concerne
les gigots et on a une question d'un
téléspectateur à ce sujet on va regarder
[Musique]
et je vous lis la question parle
beaucoup d'héritage des jeux olympiques
pour la seine-saint-denis en termes de
logements d'équipements mais pas en
terme d'emplois qu'en sera-t-il le taux
de chômage est très élevé dans notre
départ club à moi je parle et c'est même
notre préoccupation majeure je pense
comme votre téléspectateurs que cette
ces mêmes centrales dans la mesure où il
va y avoir des investissements publics
et privés massive dans le département de
la seine-saint-denis à la fois pour les
jo mais si j'y ajoute les gars du métro
du grand paris express l'installation du
campus condorcet la dgsi à saint-ouen il
y à vraiment des capacités pour
accélérer les transformations de ce
territoire mais ça ne sera réussie si
effectivement ces investissements
publics et privés profite au
développement économique profite à
l'emploi des habitants de ce territoire
et donc il faut investir massivement sur
la formation sur la qualification sur
l'insertion
il ya des objectifs très précis qui ont
été fixés notamment à la société qui
livre les équipements open olympique la
soli deo pour qu'il y ait 25 % des
marchés qu'ils soient réservés aux tpe
pme du territoire et qu'il y ait
également 10% des emplois pour
l'insertion des demandeurs d'emploi
uniques c'est une aubaine cjo pour un
département comme le vôtre mais est ce
que tout ça ne risque pas d'être gâchée
par cette crise sanitaire
mais j'ai envie de vous dire que ça doit
être l'un verse c'est parce qu'il y à
cette crise il faut maintenir cette
ambition au plus haut niveau en matière
c'est noble tous en l'état actuel des
choses cette note
mais écoutez franchement est-ce que vous
pensez que quand tu ne paies y affronter
des situations de crise terrible
je pense à des périodes de
reconstruction je pense au premier au
second choc pétrolier et maintenant il y
a dix ans la crise financière
aujourd'hui cette crise sanitaire
est ce que nous en avons rabattus en
matière d'investissement non au
contraire il faut les accélérer parce
que c'est non seulement un objectif un
moyen de faire face à la crise actuelle
mais de préparer l'avenir pour on va pas
sacrifier des générations donc au
contraire il faut y aller c'est
maintenant qu'il faut accélérer ses
investissements et ses transformations
pour les mettre au service de
l'emploi et du rattrapage est connu et
deux questions rapidement pour finir je
vais demander d'être assez bref stéphane
troussel vous serez à nouveau candidat
au départemental l'or aujourd'hui n'est
pas ni à l'annonce des candidatures ni
au choix des personnes pour moi je suis
en action avec cette majorité de gauche
écologistes et je veux surtout
rassembler les forces vives de la seine
saint denis je prendrai des initiatives
dans les jours qui viennent pour
préparer l'avenir et surtout faire face
aux responsabilités qui sont les nôtres
et deuxième question rapidement aussi il
ya le congrès du parti socialiste un qui
va qui va arriver dans deux mois et la
mer devant velin hélène geoffroy qui dit
préparer une motion concurrente à celle
d'olivier fort qui soutenez vous moi je
serai aux côtés d'olivier fort parce que
d'abord face à la situation difficile
que la gauche et le parti socialiste a
affronté depuis 2017
eh bien il est il est au travail il
rassemble les différentes sensibilités
socialistes
et puis moi je fais partie de ceux qui
pensent que la gauche le parti
socialiste doit aujourd'hui non
seulement s'ouvrir mais se dépasser dans
le cadre de nos formations actuelles ça
me paraît indispensable pour
reconstruire une force de gauche qui
soit en capacité d'incarner
l'alternative est l'avenir dans ce pays
pour éviter à nos concitoyens ce duel
duo annoncé déjà de marine le pen et
d'emmanuel macron c'est ce n'est pas
possible pour l'avenir de ce pays et
merci beaucoup merci anne roussel
d'avoir est avec nous ce matin on
regarde la une des dernières nouvelles
d'alsace fabrice un virus peut en cacher
un autre
on parle de la grippe saisonnière merci
beaucoup merci d'avoir été avec nous
mais si on passe au club de territoire
la mutuelle nationale territoriale
la mutuelle des agents des services
publics
vous présente le club des territoires
[Musique]